okay here we go we need to talk about
bad baby because she posted a picture
that appears to show that net money not
even gross money net money she brought
in 42 million dollars from only fans
over a year right and she did this
because she previously claimed she made
50 million dollars on the platform which
you can see in her gross total
apparently enough people doubted her so
she just came in hot with these receipts
the thing is like I do well for myself
but this made me feel middle class no
I'm not gonna be a hater I believe that
sex work is real work I've been very
very clear about that granted with a
specific situation it does feel a little
bit weird because there were just like
so many people waiting for her to turn
18 and she made like a million dollars
in the first six hours so there's that
creepy element but at the end of the day
when she did this she was a consenting
adult doing with her body as she pleased
and she made bank and even more
impressively right she made it off of a
weird Dr Phil interview kind of did the
reverse Kim Kardashian rather than
nudity or sex tape and then going kind
of more mainstream she did the opposite
though I will say because of the rise of
only fans that is becoming increasingly
common or you have a number of examples
on Tick Tock for example you have very
very attractive people posting thirst
trap dancing kind of lip sync videos
they then turn that into an only fans
career that makes millions upon millions
of dollars El delfian who uh just came
back to the public internet I think is a
great example of that her and others
essentially using every other social
media platform as just a free
promotional okay so I was looking into
this right because this story came out a
while ago and a lot of people
celebrating it you know she's making 18
million all this other stuff and
everyone's like
everybody's super happy for and I think
it's fantastic I just want to ask where
are these same people
you know when a 19 year old wants to
[ __ ] 35 year old and everybody lose
their mind
just ask
when a 22 year old or 21 year old wants
to [ __ ] a 40 year old oh my God that's
unacceptable I just don't understand how
somebody can turn 18. you're the only
fans everybody celebrates like this huge
Victory because she's apparently mature
enough all of a sudden right according
to these people
to do a million only fans we're getting
50 million exposing ourselves okay about
as much as she's exposing herself
apparently two random dudes all over the
internet
the thing is humans are weird okay in
the sense that we imagine stuff oh the
minute we say that girl the 19 year old
is the word of 35
we imagine them [ __ ]
and we don't like that we know their
Skin's like in contact it's confirmed
like a dirty like a donkey perm it's
like a dirty yes also like a dirty King
perm okay it's confirmed it's like uh
people don't like it it's like uh jizz
all over her face uh they don't like
that they um they imagine that okay only
fans do you just think it's just
pictures there's no interaction
if most people are like I really think
so that people are then people are weird
like that that they they absolutely they
really classify things differently as
yeah no they don't do something they
don't go inside we have a weird thing
with sexuality like that where we
imagine this thing
to me it's just funny it's just fun
that's all it is I just think it's
interesting it's a great point and I
don't care you're 18 do what you want
you can go out and grab a rifle and go
shoot people in foreign countries I
think you should choose if you want to
do only pets I don't care I just think
it's crazy that the moment the same
person wants to [ __ ] somebody way older
there's a problem she's too young oh my
gosh she's not mature enough her
prefrontal cortex haven't developed
15 mil out here chatting with old
geezers in the messages right on only
fans that's how she makes most of their
money by the way direct messages
it's not just oh subscribe I can assure
you so
I never understood this kind of
consistency it's sexual Liberation it's
I want to do what I want my body my
choice fantastic
can't [ __ ] old dude apparently because
you're not mature enough but how did
lose two things coexist because people
really are aware like that give you
another example I have a sex podcast in
French right with my co-host she's a
girl and then
um she was talking about yeah I got a 19
year old a home and I can't
his friends are not thinking about me
they can I'm like yeah there's a
possibility that your friend your kid's
friend think about you in a sexual way
it's like nah I'm not the standard I'm
not this is my yes it is and she was
like kind of I'm kind of grossed out by
it and I it was fine if it was a random
19 year old but not her son's friends
and I'm like just because of the
friendship with your son that that's the
only thing that makes it that um now
it's a no in your head that and that's
how people are weird and I understand
her why she wouldn't but yeah you could
you could understand why somebody
wouldn't yeah but I didn't but I did
this like it's a possibility right and
people just a little thing is gonna a
little parameter that really doesn't
matter at the end of the day is gonna
change and to them it changed the whole
situation you have a man a male body a
female body people thinking about
whatever that's it and it might happen
whether it is a connection with your son
or not that's a parameter that doesn't
matter it doesn't matter it's not even
part of the equation as a matter of fact
it could actually amplify the fact that
anyways all that to say humans are weird
yeah humans are weird the parallels that
we make makes no sense the shortcuts
sometimes that we make makes no sense
it's not based in logic you know what's
funny too it was like that story about
that 17 year old that 15 year old that
we're banging and the dude the 17 year
old guy who's being the 15 year old
right they were in relationship took a
picture of her naked body and like
consenting and they charged him with
holding Graphics yay and I'm like so he
could be Insider he can't just take a
photo of her yes yes and everyone's like
yeah cause nowadays I was like does that
send him to jail I'm like what did you
hear what you just said it made those
hands but again we have a very strange
relationship with sex okay we have a
very weird relationship where we have
two things happening simultaneously on
one hand you are grown enough to do
whatever you want on the other well
these are all the ways you're not grown
enough
imagine as an adult if that's really how
things worked for the most part and I
know we have some stupid laws I know in
America for example they have one law
where it's like you can't drink until
you're 21 but you can go shoot people
and do whatever you want it's like and
we also know every college student is
drinking okay they're at their parties
they're getting wasted it's happening
but anyways they're not old enough no
they're not old enough it's one of those
dumb laws not possibly do that yes yes
they can go out there and grab weed in
legal states right because once you're
18 you can start smoking impossible
it doesn't need to make sense
but for the vast majority of things once
you hit 18 you're good to go we
acknowledger as an adult we give you the
right to vote which is one of the
biggest privileges that you can have as
a person you can buy homes you can do
all the stuff yes
and it speaks to the weird relationship
that folks have when it comes to sex one
and two it also speaks to the way
Society tries to frame everything as
women are both simultaneously developing
faster than men and simultaneously not
old enough to handle sex
because they're too immature apparently
there that's one of the funny things
remember that you say that the women's
Brains developed because of social
but they can't at 19.
I see this stuff when I just laugh at it
from afar
because I'm the type of person who's
like well have whatever freedoms you
want once you're old enough like
whatever unless this person's Your
Guardian the person who is your manager
or
you know your police officer some crazy
thing like that I don't care
but everybody else is like nah you can't
you can't do that and I don't know to me
it just makes me I just think it's funny
yeah I just wanted to bring that up real
quick I understand shout out to Bar
about bad baby or whatever bad Barbie
baby
bad baby you can't call or catch me I
saw girls who don't like that all right
so they catch me outside girl uh shout
out to her she made a lot of money you
know what I mean no no hate on that at
all Ms bergoli so yeah I just want to
bring that up real quick